Hi ihr Lieben!
Heute kommt ein ganz besonderes Video,
denn ganz, ganz viele von euch haben über das Jahr 2019 hinweg gefragt:
"Kiki, was benutzt du für eine Küchenmaschine?"
Euch ist wahrscheinlich aufgefallen, dass ich diese hier seit Anfang des Jahres teste.
Und ich habe mir jetzt meine Meinung gebildet und kann euch ausgiebig darüber informieren,
was für Vorteile sie bringt.
Das hier ist die Sage Bakery Boss und ich habe sie jetzt wirklich seit einem Jahr im Gebrauch,
in den Videos aber auch außerhalb der Videos.
Und was ich vorneweg sagen kann:
für mich war es wichtig, eine Küchenmaschine zu haben,
die leise ist aber leistungsstark.
Und das haben wir hier zu 100% erfüllt.
Was mir persönlich jetzt noch ganz, ganz wichtig ist
bevor ich hier zu diesen Facts übergehe und euch erkläre,
warum die Maschine gut ist - oder warum auch nicht, das erfahrt ihr dann am Ende des Videos -
möchte ich euch noch sagen: dieses Video ist nicht gesponsert,
es ist alles selbst bezahlt und ich erhalte für keine meiner Aktionen
Werbegeld von der Firma Sage. Nur dass ihr das im Voraus wisst.
Und jetzt gehen wir Mal über zu den Fakten: Was kann sie?
Wie sind so diese Eckdaten, die Zahlen? Das gucken wir uns jetzt einmal an.
Meine Küchenmaschine hat sagenhafte 1200 Watt und was mir persönlich
aber ganz, ganz wichtig ist: dass der Motor nicht überhitzt.
Der Motor ist ein Drehmoment-starker Motor, der hier innen verbaut ist.
Und ich merke das vor allem, wenn ich z.B. Teige, also vor allem
schwere Sachen mixe oder wenn ich sehr, sehr lange mixe.
Ich erinnere euch gerne an mein çiğköfte Rezept, da habe ich ganze 96 çiğköfte
in der Maschine geknetet weil ich einfach keine Lust hatte,
das Ganze 2x zu kneten und 2x 20min lang zu kneten.
Ich glaube, auch das würde der schaffen aber 1x 20min die ganze çiğköfte Masse,
die hat er gepackt. Und das war für mich der Moment, wo ich dachte:
"Dankeschön, dass du mir die Arbeit erleichterst!"
Und noch ein Zusatz: die Bakery Boss besistzt eine Load-Sensing Technologie.
Das heißt falls ihr mal schwere Back- oder Rührteige habt,
erkennt sie das automatisch an und passt die Geschwindigkeit so an,
dass sie immer in der gleichen notwendigen Geschwindigkeit rührt.
Außerdem hat die Maschine ein Motor-Schutz System. Was genau bedeutet das?
Falls ihr jetzt - was ja wirklich passieren kann -
einmal viel, viel länger schlägt als vorgegeben
und die Maschine läuft und läuft und läuft, dann kennt ihr das ja,
wenn bei kleinen Geräten wirklich mal der Motor überhitzt
und dann läuft die Maschine garnicht mehr, ihr müsst sie zur Reperatur geben;
einfach nur unnötiger Stress!
Das Motor-Schutz System ist einfach daher sinnvoll, dass es wirklich aufhört zu rühren,
wenn es merkt: "Oh, gleich könnte der Motor durchbrennen.
Ich höre jetzt lieber auf und kühle etwas ab."
Und das Tolle ist nicht nur, dass eben ihr dieses Motor-Schutz System habt.
Ihr habt zusätzlich noch eine verlängerte Garantie, das heißt 5 Jahre Garantie auf den Motor.
Was ich persönlich richtig cool fand - und das ist auch echt das erste,
was mir ins Auge gestochen ist, als ich die Maschine gekauft habe - ist der Timer.
Ich liebe den Timer!
Weil manchmal ist es echt so: ich muss eine Eiermasse 8min schlagen
oder eine Buttermasse 12min und dann hab ich den Timer,
muss mir nicht extra auf'm Handy den Timer stellen oder immer wieder auf die Uhrzeit achten,
sondern kann hier wirklich auf 8min zum Beispiel.
Also ich drücke einfach die Pfeiltaste, geh auf 8min hoch,
mach die Maschine an und dann geht sie auch echt von alleine aus, macht einen ganz kleinen
Piep und dann weiß ich: "Ah ok, ich muss wieder zur Maschine
und die nächste Zutat reintun."
Das, was wir immer benötigen wenn die Maschine im Gebrauch ist,
ist der Geschwindigkeitsregler.
Hier habt ihr einmal den Off-Knopf, dann ist die Maschine ganz einfach
nicht im Betrieb aber schon an.
Dann haben wir den Pause-Knopf, dann geht auch schon das Lichtlein an, das ist
auch so ein cooles Gimmick, was ihr noch zusätzlich habt:
ein Licht! Dann könnt ihr eure Teige besser sehen, wenn eure Küche nicht so stark beleuchtet ist,
und könnt genau sehen, wie euer Teig bzw. eure Rührmasse gerade aussieht.
Und dann unterscheiden wir zwischen 12 Geschwindigkeitsstufen.
Ihr braucht je nachdem, was ihr macht, eine andere Geschwindigkeitsstufe.
Macht ihr jetzt z.B. Eischnee, dann nehmt ihr die höchste.
Oder macht ihr nur einen Teig, einen Hefeteig, dann nehmt ihr Geschwindigkeitsstufe 1-3.
Und so hat eben jedes Rezept seine eigene Stufe.
Kommen wir nochmal kurz zur Pause-Funktion.
Die finde ich persönlich deshalb so wichtig, weil ihr - vor allem
wenn ihr Backanfänger seid, aber auch bei Fortgeschrittenen - ihr die Zeit
nicht mehr im Blick habt und denkt: "Oh mein Gott, wir lange hab ich jetzt diese Eier geschlagen?
Sind sie jetzt schon fluffig genug?"
Dann seht ihr hier ganz genau wie viele Minuten das sind, geht auf Pause und nicht auf Off!
Auf Pause denn dann wird die Zeit gestoppt, also angehalten
und wenn ihr dann die weiteren Zutaten hinzufügt und weiterdreht,
dann geht die Zahl wieder ganz normal hoch und nimmt seinen Lauf und geht eben nicht auf 0.
Und was ich z.B. mir manchmal denke - ich bin jetzt keine Mutter
aber bei Müttern, die z.B. das Baby gerade füttern und denken:
"Wie lange hat die jetzt schon geschlagen?" Dann steht's alles hier drauf,
ihr müsst euch nicht noch Sachen im Hinterkopf merken, die Maschine
erledigt das für euch.
Kommen wir jetzt von den Geschwindigkeitsstufen einmal zum Gehäuse.
Das hier ist keineswegs Plastik, sondern massives druckgegossenes Metall,
also hochwertiges Edelstahl.
Und hier am Motorkopf haben wir tatsächlich auch schon den Entriegelungsknopf,
das heißt ihr drückt einmal - ich mach's gerne mit einer Hand - und dann könnt ihr
die Maschine anheben und hier kommen dann die Kneteinsätze rein.
Was ich euch jetzt noch sagen kann an Informationen, was für mich ziemlich wichtig ist
wenn ich sie jetzt z.B. verschenke an meine Mutter oder wenn ihr sie an die Großmutter verschenkt:
die Maschine ist wertig und schwer dementsprechend, es ist ja kein Plastik.
Aber eben dass man sie mit einem Handgriff auf- und zubekommt, finde ich persönlich
ist sehr sehr wichtig. Gerade für ältere Menschen, die dann eben nicht so viel Kraft haben.
Und falls sie dann doch noch ein bisschen Hilfe und Unterstützung brauchen:
einfach hier oben den Griff anfassen und dann kann man so auch ganz einfach die Maschine bedienen
und kippt nicht gleich mit dem ganzen Körper nach vorne und nach hinten.
Jetzt kommen wir aber mal zu den Zubehör-Teilen der Bakery Boss
und zwar ist wohl das allerwichtigste der Schneebesen-Aufsatz!
Den benutze ich persönlich auch am aller, allermeisten tatsächlich
und den gebt ihr jetzt einfach so rein. Und das ist halt sehr gut geeignet
für Baisermassen, für Rührteige, die besonders luftig sein sollen.
Und das Geniale ist, dass wir hier ein Planeten-Rührwerk haben.
Das heißt ähnlich wie bei Konditoreien oder professionellen Patisserien dreht sich hier das Rührelement
im und das Rührwerk gegen den Uhrzeigersinn.
Also wird der ganze Inhalt der gesamten Schüssel gepackt.
Hier haben wir jetzt den Knethaken und den verwendet ihr am allerbesten für Hefeteige
wenn ihr mal wieder Brot backen möchtet.
Und dann am besten auch eine der niedrigen Stufen verwenden, das ist für Hefeteig immer am allerbesten.
Den Rührhaken am allerbesten für schwere Teige wie z.B. schwere Kuchenteige verwenden,
wo die Eier nicht seperat aufgeschlagen werden.
Ihr könnt damit auch wunderbar Kartoffelpüree z.B.machen,
also wirklich alles, was sehr, sehr schwer ist.
Das hier ist eines meiner persönlichen Highlights wenn ich ganz ehrlich bin,
das verwende ich genauso oft wie den Schneebesen-Aufsatz.
Und zwar ist das der Rührhaken mit Gummilippe.
Und das besondere daran ist: Ihr kennt mich ja mittlerweile. Manchmal sag ich ja:
"Hebt z.B. die Baisermasse mit ganz viel Liebe und einem Teigschaber unter!"
und das ist eben genau das, was ich meine.
Das ist euer Teigschaber mit ganz viel Liebe!
Ihr setzt den einfach auf und wenn ihr dann die Baisermasse unterhebt,
dann ganz einfach einfügen und gaaanz langsam rühren.
Und die Gummilippe sorgt dafür, dass ihr alles vom Rand auch einholt
und nichts irgendwie am Rand kleben bleibt.
Das gleiche Problem habt ihr bei Butter wenn ich sage "Butter aufschlagen"
und ihr fangt z.B.mit eurer alten Küchenmaschine an zu schlagen und ihr merkt:
"Okay es ist Butter am Rand, die wird gar nicht verarbeitet.
Die Butter in der Mitte ist schon ganz hell-cremig und die am Rand außen
ist immernoch so gelblich."
Und dann nehmt ihr eben immer den Rührhaken mit der schönen Gummilippe!
Im Lieferumfang sind übrigens 2 Schüsseln enthalten und ich finde 2 Schüsseln auch immer ganz wichtig,
denn manchmal braucht ihr eine für eine Baisermasse, also zum Eiweiß aufschlagen
und müsst dann direkt in der anderen Schüssel weiter machen,
daher perfekt, dass es 2 sind.
Hier haben wir einmal eine Glasschüssel, das ist Borosilikatglas
das heißt ihr könnt sie in die Spülmaschine tun, in die Mikrowelle.
4,7l Fassungsvermögen, also mega, top! Darauf achte ich nämlich auch immer sehr.
Und was ihr auch noch habt ist eine Edelstahl-Schüssel, könnt ihr auch in die Spülmaschine geben für die einfache Reinigung,
das sind 3,8l Fassungsvermögen.
Ihr bekommt zusätzlich einen Spritzschutz mitgeliefert, das heißt er dient nicht nur als Spritzschutz,
sondern auch als Eingieß-Hilfe oder Einschütt-Hilfe, falls ihr mal Zucker
oder Mehl einfach hier über die Öffnung mit dazu geben möchtet.
Der passt sowohl auf die Glasschüssel als auch auf die Edelstahlschüssel.
Ein letztes Zubehör-Teil möchte ich euch jetzt präsentieren und zwar ist das der Deckel.
Vermutlich für euch nur ein gewöhnlicher Deckel, für mich aber sehr hilfreich
wenn ihr z.B. Hefeteige knetet: Deckel drauf machen und direkt in der Schüssel ruhen lassen.
Und ihr könnt den Deckel auch gerne auf die Edelstahlschüssel geben, das heißt auch wie beim Prinzip vorher
mit dem Spritzschutz passt der Deckel auf beide Schüsseln. Und das Geniale ist:
Ihr bekommt im Set wirklich alle beide Schüsseln. Also nicht wie man's kennt,
dass man nur die eine Schüssel bekommt und sich die andere extra dazu bestellen muss, sondern
es ist alles schon - das, was ihr heute im Video gesehen habt - im Paket mit dabei.
Für mich nochmal ein Riesen Pluspunkt: beide Schüsseln sowie diese 3 Rühr-Elemente
sind komplett Spülmaschinen-geeignet. Beim Schneebesen-Aufsatz rate ich euch: Spült's lieber mit der Hand
damit ihr auch wirklich die Langlebigkeit habt.
Für mich war das allerletzte K.O. Kriterium die Lautstärke, denn ich hatte vorher eine Küchenmaschine,
die war extrem laut wenn sie auf der höchsten Stufe war,
teilweise auch auf den Stufen drunter.
Und ich konnte mich in einem Raum nicht mit Hamza unterhalten.
Also ich konnte mich mit meinem eigenen Mann wenn wir im gleichen Raum waren
und die Maschine einfach mal die Eier schlägt nicht unterhalten
und wir mussten uns anschreien.
Und das ist eben bei dieser Maschine nicht der Fall.
Die ist deutlich leiser, auch auf der höchsten Stufe und mit einer deutlich besseren -
meiner Meinung nach - einer deutlich besseren Leistungsstärke.
Und jetzt möchte ich euch noch etwas sagen, das mir persönlich sehr am Herzen liegt.
Denn ihr wisst ja, dass auf meinen Schultern so ein bisschen der Druck lastet, dass wenn ich was zeige,
der Zuschauer gleich denkt: "Ok, das Produkt ist gut. Kiki benutzt das,
also ist dieses Produkt gut!"
Daher hab ich euch jetzt 1 Jahr lang hingehalten und konnte euch 1 Jahr lang keine Fragen beantworten
zu: "Was ist das für eine Küchenmaschine? Ist die gut? Bist du zufrieden?
Wie heißt die? Ich will sie unbedingt bestellen!"
Daher verzeiht's mir, dass ich euch jetzt ein bisschen hingehalten hab.
Im Endeffekt muss ich sagen: Die Maschine ist top, auch was Preis-Leistung angeht,
was die Power angeht, die Lautstärke, die Zubehör-Teile.
Ihr könnt sie gerne bei mir im Shop erwerben, hier kommen wir auch schon zum nächsten Teil.
Für mich ist das so: wenn ich was in meinen Shop aufnehme,
dann muss es auch wirklich eine top Qualität haben und es muss auch sein Geld wert sein.
Ich hab die Küchenmaschine jetzt in meinen Shop aufgenommen, steh dafür mit meinem Gesicht,
das heißt wenn sie irgendwie in irgendeiner Form schlecht wäre,
dann fällt das alles auf mich zurück.
Und deshalb könnt ihr euch sicher sein: diese Maschine ist wirklich sehr, sehr, sehr empfehlenswert.
So und jetzt möchte ich euch so langsam verabschieden.
Ich bin dankbar dafür, dass ihr bis hierhin geschaut habt
und wenn ihr weitere Fragen habt, Kommentare dann schreibt's mir doch gerne hier drunter,
dann können wir uns auch gerne austauschen.
Ich setze euch den Link zur Maschine auch in die Infobox
Und ansonsten sehen wir uns bei meinem nächsten Video.
Tschüss, eure Kiki!